if we think about procrastination as a
coping method for dealing with these
difficult task rated emotions right what
happens when you're in a situation where
you've got a whole bunch of other things
to cope with like a pandemic and the
health of yourself and your family your
financial well-being and job insecurity
and uncertainty of when this thing's
going to end and all this sort of thing
that's going to eat up all your coping
resources or most of them and now you've
got those nasty reports that you've
never written before you're uncertainty
you don't know what you're doing you
can't go over somebody at the desk
because you're working remotely and what
are you going to do well quick and easy
dirty method it works you're going to
procrastinate it right you just manage
your mood and you've saved you know you
know basically protected those coping
resources those limited coping resources
you have to deal with all the other big
background
stuff